what made Bruce Lee such an icon was not
as portfolio of martial-arts films but
rather his philosophy this is what
elevated him above other film stars at
the time and cemented him as a legend
with a legacy that would outlast his
films but what exactly was Bruce Lee's
philosophy all about if you dig a little
deeper than the handful of quotes and
memes circulating the web what do you
find how does his philosophy define who
he was and ultimately dictate the course
of his career and personal development
in this video we're going to find out
[Music]
Bruce Lee studied philosophy along with
psychology in numerous other subjects at
the University of Washington from 1961
onwards philosophy was not a passing
interest then but rather a lifelong
pursuit as crucial to the man as his
martial arts it's also interesting to
put Bruce Lee's philosophies into
context by considering his influences of
course Bruce Lee was Chinese living in
the USA which instantly gave him an
interesting dualism as we'll see the
roots of many of his ideas also lie in
the study of martial arts and
particularly Wing Chun and don't forget
as well that Bruce Lee was alive during
the 60s when Eastern philosophies were
particularly in vogue it should come as
no surprise then that Bruce had
countless musings and notes on a diverse
range of topics like any good polymath
Bruce Lee kept copious notes that
recorded his training regime along with
his diet his philosophical musings and
more he always carried a 2x3 pocket book
and perhaps this predilection for
note-taking is the first thing we can
learn from him it is from these
notebooks that many of his views and
ideas have been gleaned covering
practically every topic Under the Sun
recently did not just write about
martial arts to demonstrate this
diversity consider this passage on the
nature of ideas there are three types of
ideas innate ideas inborn adventitious
ideas from outside events factitious
ideas which one invents it's almost like
reading Sun Tzu so if I were to try and
cover all of Bruce Lee's thoughts and
ideas this would be a very long video
indeed instead let's appear on what
appears to be the essence behind many of
these ideas the governing principle if
you wish by using something akin to
qualitative analysis I've had a look at
a lot of his notes and his ideas and
I've looked for recurring themes and
that way hopefully you can see if
there's a case of narrative that we can
take from all this so if we're to look
through all of Bruce Lee's notes and
quotes then one concept arises more than
any other battle flow this is
exemplified by one of his most famous
quotes this is what it is okay
I said empty your mind be formless
shapeless like water now you put water
into a cup it becomes the cup you put
water into a bottle it becomes the
bottle you're putting a teapot it
becomes the teapot now water can flow
oh it can crash be water my friend as
well as many more lesser-known ones one
of my favorite quotes moving be like
water still be like a mirror respond
like an echo or to put this bite-sized
morsel within its larger context flow in
the living moment we are always in a
process of becoming and nothing is fixed
have no rigid system in you and you'll
be flexible to change with the
ever-changing open yourself and flow my
friend flow in the total openness of the
living moment if nothing within you
stays rigid outward things will disclose
themselves moving me like water still be
like a mirror respond like an echo this
can be interpreted in many ways one of
the most obvious connections to draw is
to the martial arts application it
appears that Bruce Lee is advising us as
they adaptable to our opponents and
almost describing motion the Zen
expression of mind without mind and
motion as I've explained on my website
can be equated roughly to being in a
flow state is the mental state when all
other things fall away and your present
purely in the moment this makes you
faster to respond faster to adapt and
less distracted by outside thoughts
today we know that this state roughly
correlates with a reduced activation in
the prefrontal cortex called temporal
hypofrontality and the state is
reportedly experienced by many top level
athletes as well as creative types
during their peak performance
Bruce speaks of being in the moment the
moment has no yesterday or tomorrow it
is not the result of thought and
therefore has no time being in the
moment can also be likened to more
modern mindfulness practices and indeed
Bruce's descriptions bear remarkable
similarity listen can you hear the wind
and can you hear the birds singing you
have to hear it empty your mind you know
how water fills a cup it becomes that
cup you have to think about nothing you
have to become enough
this liquid flowing state can also see
application and kung-fu practices such
as pushing hands and Bruce has alluded
to this concept directly there is
another bit of Chinese philosophy that
has a bearing on problems common to all
humankind we say the oak tree is mighty
yet it will be destroyed by a mighty
wind because it resists the elements the
bamboo bends with the wind and by
bending survives he also developed this
idea further in his own words the law of
harmony in which one should be in
harmony with and not in the opposition
to the strength and force of the
opposition this means that one should do
nothing that is not natural or
spontaneous the important thing is not
to strain in any way this is seen income
free when defending against strikes the
objective here is not to block the
strikes head-on but rather to redirect
the energy gently the fighter thereby
exerts less energy feels this impact
from the blow and is able to put the
assailant off-balance using their own
force when performed correctly it should
feel almost as though they are fighting
a ghost the idea of remaining adaptable
flexible and flowing can also be applied
in other ways for example it can be seen
as a retaliation against strict forms
traditions and practices which is
essentially what gave birth to Jeet Kune
Do Jeet Kune Do is Bruce Lee's own
approach to fighting that seeks to do
away with the classical mess rigid forms
and structures are meaningless and say
why should one wrote to learn elaborate
routines or add unnecessary flourishes
to their movements why should a fighter
be Wed to one style of martial art at
all when all that does is to limit their
options Jeet Kune Do is the way of the
intercepting fist and it teaches the
fighter to take the shortest and most
powerful and instinctual line of attack
it teaches them not to anticipate but to
respond and to do so in the way that is
most natural expression of that
individual in Cantonese deep Kundel the
way of the intercepting fist
intercepting first or
come on touch me any way you can
you see to reach me you must move to me
door attack offers me an opportunity to
intercept you in this case I'm using my
longest weapon bicycling against the
nearest target Renuka Bruce Lee's final
film The Game of Death was to
demonstrate the futility of sticking too
rigid fighting forms and the importance
of adaptability you know baby this
bamboo is longer more flexible and very
much alive when your flashy routines
cannot keep up with ski neelu sickness
this thing here all I can say is you got
to be in deep trouble in that film Bruce
Lee was going to ascend a pagoda
fighting masses of various different
disciplines on his way to the top his
character fights using a free and fluid
style akin to Jeet Kune Do and this
allows him to neutralize each opponent
Bruce's weapons in the film would even
reflect this nunchukas
and a green bamboo whip both too fast
and too lights to block or anticipate
the idea flowing like water can also be
applied to many other areas of one's
life the idea of ignoring convention and
structure in favor of flexibility for
example can help to create harmony among
religious groups two religions divide
people just the styles in martial arts
divide people if all the religions of
the world will one world be united in
Brotherhood constantly flowing and
moving pores can also be a key to
happiness learn to walk on why add the
tension of emotion and thoughts to a
situation which is illusion to the
extent that it is real of a passing
moment in any event the result of
previous causes do what seems wise to be
done forget it and walk on walk on and
see a new view walk on and see the birds
fly walk on and leave behind all things
that would dam up the inlet or clog the
outlet of experience
and even the health the method for
health promotion is based on water as
flowing water never gross sale the idea
is not to over develop or overexert but
to normalize the function of the body
and here's what I find so awesome about
Bruce that he honed his body to become a
living testament to the philosophies by
which he led his life his power fluidity
of movement speed and quickness of wit
all allowed him to respond as a
situation demanded and to truly and
swiftly express himself in the moment
this comes across in his films and I
feel it's the real reason that you say
magnetic to watch then you have to train
you have to keep your reflexes so that
when you want it it's there when you
want to move you're moving and when you
move you're determined to move not
taking one inch not anything less than
that if I want to punch I'm gonna do it
man and I'm gonna do what you seen so I
mean so that is the type of thing you
have to train yourself into it to become
one with the you think this is very
earnest earnest attitude Bruce also
believes strongly in the power of will
in self-development and in achieving
self-actualization this was around 1954
when Maslow described actualization in
his hierarchy of human motivation so
again this thinking may be a product of
the time Bruce Lee believed in
fulfilling your destiny on using mantras
and self affirmations again similar to
cognitive behavioral therapy he believed
in reading copious amounts and on
repetitious training in the extreme but
how do these notions gel with the idea
of being free and flowing is exerting
your will and learning a set knowledge
not a contradiction to being able to
adapt and go with the flow not entirely
if you think of yourself as a crucial
part of nature that your will is
something that exists within and that
simply needs to be expressed and going
with the flow means going with your own
nature being true to who you are and
working in harmony with your
circumstances to express that true self
to the fullest knowledge and repetition
are simply tools that can be used to
help you fulfill your own purpose and
should not be seen as absolute truths
and should not be allowed to guide or
mold you into a different person
as Bruce would say or type of knowledge
ultimately rules self normal you should
absorb what is useful and discard what
is not instead of dedicating your life
to actualize a concept of what you
should be like actualize yourself the
process of maturing does not mean to
become a captive of conceptualization it
is to come to the realization of what
lies in our innermost selves many of us
struggle to be here we are and instead
find ourselves trying to live up to
others ideas of what we should be to
societal norms or to our herd instinct
this is when we are going against our
true nature and this is when our words
and actions lose their conviction and
their power the power that Bruce was so
known for but to express oneself
honestly not lying to oneself and to
express myself once you know that my
phone is very hard to do what a
self-willed mean does it not mean having
a will of one's own the human herd
instinct demands adaptation and
subordination but for his highest honors
man elects not the meek the
pusillanimous the supine but precisely
the self willed man the heroes another a
self willed man has no other aim than
his own growth he values only one thing
the mysterious peril in self which bids
him live and helps him to grow his only
living destiny is the silent and gain
sable law in his own heart which
comfortable habits make it so hard to
obey for which the self world man is
destined and Godhead in other words it
is when we deny our true nature and will
that we meet resistance even if it might
seem easier at first to go along with
those comfortable habits and those laws
the yielding will has a repurpose filiz
softest downy feathers a quietude
a shrinking from action and appearance
of inability to do the heart is humble
but the work is forceful placidly free
from anxiety one acts in harmony with
nature one moves and revolves in the
line of creation practice and research
allows us to better fulfill our will but
we must concentrate on the moon not the
finger and we mustn't settle on one set
of ideas or allow them to stop us from
growing an intelligent mind is one that
is constantly learning never concluding
styles and patterns have come to
conclusion therefore they have ceased to
be intelligent absorb what is useful
discard what is useless and add what is
specifically your own of course there
are some contradictions in Bruce Lee's
thinking and this is to be expected
after all we have only collections of
notes written at different points during
his life as the very nature of his
philosophy demands Bruce's ideas were
constantly changing flowing and
developing and who are we to say whether
his latter ideas should trump the former
all we can do is listen to his teachings
reflect on them and then move forwards
allowing them to empower our own
philosophy and purpose a teacher is
never a giver of truth he is a guide a
pointer to the truth that each student
must find for himself a good teacher is
merely a catalyst it is like a finger
pointing away to the moon don't
concentrate on the finger or you will
miss all that heavenly glory do you
understand the biggest tragedy of course
is that Bruce was never able to fully
develop and evolve his ideas as he was
struck down before his time who knows
what new insights he might have come to
but even on the subject of death
Bruce was philosophical the round of
summer and winter becomes a blessing the
moment we give up the fantasy of eternal
spring remembrance is the only paradise
out of which we cannot be driven away
pleasure is the flower that fades
remembrance is the lasting perfume
remembrances last longer than present
realities I have preserved blossoms for
many years but never fruits
as always guys thanks very much for
watching I hope you found this
interesting I was trying something a bit
different here that seems like I'm
always trying something a bit different
anyways if you did find it interesting
then please consider liking the video
sharing leaving a comment below and
maybe subscribing to the channel you can
also check out my blog over at the
Pioneer com
stay tuned and I'll see you next time
bye for now